Okay, welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips.
This month, we're looking at positive problem solving.
Now, a big part of life and especially business life is dealing with problems.
This can be difficult but don't worry.
Today, I'm going to introduce three positive problem solving approaches.
First one: positive speaking.
Now, positive speaking is very simple but very powerful.
Instead of using negative thinking and language,...
...use positive speaking to add positive energy.
For example, make a list of your problems using the most negative language.
Then, on the other side, write a column, opportunities.
Rewrite each problem into an opportunity.
Second: solution path.
Again, this gets away from a negative approach to problem solving.
Identify where do you want to be,...
...we call the ideal situation.
Then, what is the actual situation now.
Then, design a path to take you from the actual to the ideal.
Then, you're not solving problems...
...but you're moving along your path to the ultimate solution.
Third: appreciative inquiry.
This is a really positive approach.
Instead of focusing on what's not working in your company,...
...look at what is working well.
The good points, the strengths and the positives.
Discover what is working well within your team or company, or product.
Then, dream how can you make it even better.
Similar to that ideal situation.
Third step: design a plan to take you there...
...using the strong points your team or company has.
And finally, deliver.
Introduce that as an action plan.
So, here are three techniques to help you turn problems into opportunities.
Good luck!